[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo ici au
parlement européen à strasbourg plus que
cinq semaines avant les élections
européennes et nous continuons dans
cette édition notre tour d'europe cap
aujourd'hui sur l'italie pays fondateur
de l'union européenne qui fait beaucoup
parler de lui depuis près d'un an et
l'arrivée au pouvoir d'une coalition
contre nature composée du mouvement anti
système 5 étoiles et de la ligue
nous verrons dans notre reportage que
c'est le parti d'extrême droite qui
semble aujourd'hui surpasser son allié
débat à suivre dans cette émission mais
je vous propose d'abord de faire le tour
de l'actualité européenne des derniers
jours avec aurait dit à face
[Musique]
les sociaux-démocrates reviennent au
pouvoir en finlande
vingt ans après sa dernière victoire la
formation de gauche est arrivé en tête
des élections législatives du weekend
dernier
elle dispose d'une très courte avance
sur le parti des vrais finlandais un
parti d'extrême droite eurosceptique le
chef de file des sociaux-démocrates va
désormais devoir composer une coalition
de gouvernement
en roumanie le parti de gauche au
pouvoir embarrasse les socialistes
européens alors que le pays est dans le
collimateur de l'union européenne pour
une réforme de la justice controversée
les alliés européens du parti
social-démocrate roumains ont décidé de
geler leurs relations avec cette
formation de gouvernement
le sort du psd au sein de la gauche
européenne devra figurer formellement à
l'ordre du jour d'une réunion au mois de
juin pour éviter une guerre commerciale
avec les etats-unis les européens
veulent négocier un accord avec
washington
les échanges devons porter sur les biens
industriels
la france a marqué une opposition de
principe à l'ouverture de ses
discussions avec un pays opposé à
l'accord de paris sur le climat mais les
27 autres états membres ont voté pour
l'ouverture des négociations
c'est donc désormais à washington
d'accepter cette proposition de paix
commercial les européens repousse la
date du brds excite réunis en sommet
extraordinaire les dirigeants des
vingt-sept ont accepté un nouveau report
uniquement pour laisser le temps
nécessaire à l'adoption de l'accord de
retrait avec une date butoir le 31
octobre 2019
un choix protecteur selon emmanuel
macron 7 buts et du 31 octobre nous
protège parce que soit ils ont un accord
et c'est très bien et nous pouvons à ce
moment-là discuter des relations futures
et poursuivre notre cheminement
soit ils décident eux mêmes de retirer
le break site soit de toute façon le
no10 qui n'est pas notre préférence
reste une option
la balle est désormais dans le camp des
britanniques et pourront discuter j'ai
le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce plateau
de charles tannock bonjour bonjour vous
êtes britannique député européen
conservateur depuis 20 ans dans ce
parlement
alors avant de tenter d'analyser des
implications de ce nouveau report du
breakbeat j'aimerais que l'on revienne
rapidement un sur cette actualité qui a
touché la france et sa capitale en début
de semaine cet incendie de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris un bijou d'histoire
et d'architecturé
j'imagine que l'émotion autour de cet
événement elle va bien au delà des
frontières de la france charles tannock
bien sûr
moi je suis au pays catholiques aussi
j'adore paris j'aime j'adore la france
c'est une tragédie un grand-père au mois
on la sauve et la plupart de la
cathédrale
c'est un petit patrimoine européen c'est
un patrimoine européen et global même
cette année iconique pour tout le monde
dans le monde entier
c'est une grande tragédie et ma mère qui
habite à paris elle était elle était en
larmes tout ça comme beaucoup de
parisiens on va revenir maintenant sur
le brésil et les implications de cette
de ce report avec est bien la première
conséquence directe on sait la
participation probable du royaume uni
aux élections européennes si l'accord
n'est pas votée d'ici le 23 mai alors
cette semaine
ici à strasbourg ça devait ça devait
être votre dernière semaine en tant que
député européen mais ce sera peut-être
pas le cas puisque vous avez l'intention
de vous présenter sur les listes de
votre parti comment vous abordez ce
scrutin particulier c'est un peu bizarre
bien sûr marché européen je suis j'ai
toujours dit que le bridge pour moi
c'est un erreur mais le peuple a voté en
2016 il ya
les réfrène de madame et a fait les
grands efforts et se force pour
respecter le voile du peuple en 2016 et
là elle a ou sur l'accord de retraite et
n'a pas ou l'appui de l'opposition mais
aussi de certains députés de la droite
de mon parti on va voir maintenant si
elle a avec ses le rapprochement qu'elle
a fait avec monsieur cobain pour trouver
un compromis peut-être dans l'union
douanière ça va fonctionner mais c'est
probable qu'il y aura des élections
européennes maintenant et moi j'espère
être candidat et de représenter le
relais toujours fait pendant 20 ans et
faire tout le mieux pour le citoyen qui
votent pour moi les britanniques
j'imagine en effet ont lieu presque
trois ans après le référendum comment
les britanniques abordent ce scrutin
vous conseiller c'est intéressant et ils
ont fait des sondages et la majorité où
ils sont favorables aux en différant à
l'élection européen il ya 40% qui sont
fâchés qu'il y aura des élections est le
problème c'est que il y a les partis de
droite extrême droite qui veulent sortir
il ya deux partis eurosceptiques
maintenant à leur avis les élections
sont une espèce de deuxième référendum
mais c'est pas comme ça parce que c'est
pas réservé aux députés qui peuvent
décider la sortie
résultat des négociations c'est ça c'est
dans les mains des deux pas l'amour
nationale des députés nationaux par les
eurodéputés
alors justement ce compromis enfin ce
report pardon c'est un compromis est
risqué pour les européens puisque les
britanniques vont pouvoir peser sur le
scrutin européen certains partisans du
président ont déjà annoncé la couleur
on écoute si nous sommes obligés de
rester dans l'union nous devrions
devenir le membre le plus difficile
possible parce que je ne pense pas que
l'union européenne et son jargon s'est
comporté envers soi avec une sincère
volonté de coopérer je ne pense pas qu
une coopération sincère puisse inclure
une volonté de casser l'unité d'un état
membre lorsqu'il quitte l'union
européenne alors les européens auraient
souhaité tourner la page du break site
avant les européennes mais le dossier
risque d'interférer
dans la campagne dans ces élections mais
dans le travail même du futur parlement
jake brice mort guinée ne représente pas
la position officielle ni du
gouvernement ni du parti conservateur
il est chef d'une faction de droite
eurosceptique dans mon parti il est très
important dans cet aspect-là
mais ils ne parlent pas officiellement
pour le gouvernement et la coopération
sincère existera encore la plupart des
eurodéputés élus ici si nous sommes réel
où nous respecterons le parlement
européen et les traiter tout ça et moi
je serais si je suis réélu pour
présenter des entrées de mon pays pas
pour détruire le projet européen c'est
ça c'est vraiment c'est comme le
commentaire fait par riise manque
vraiment à mon avis c'est très négative
destructif au dernier conseil européen
on a vu se dessiner d'importantes lignes
de fracture entre les états membres il y
avait d'un côté donc l'allemagne une
quinzaine de pays qui souhaitait un
report le plus long possible et puis il
y avait de l'autre la france qui
souhaitait au contraire une extension la
plus courte possible alors les européens
étaient restés plutôt unis dans ce
dossier jusqu'à présent mais là le
dossier du breakbeat semble les diviser
il savait jusqu'au couple franco
allemand
écoutez les sommets sont toujours en
premier à la fin entre une position des
allemands des français des italiens etc
alors on a fini avec la date d'octobre
la fin d'octobre 31 octobre
c'est aussi possible il faudra avoir une
autre fondation je ne sais pas parce que
il ya la question de non seulement
d'avoir son accord de retraite
appuyé par le gouvernement britannique
il ya aussi beaucoup de 2008 ont
maintenant dans le parlement national
pour surtout dans le parti socialiste
travailliste qui veulent une belle série
friends
tout ça a besoin du temps et peut-être
aussi des élections anticipées ont
vraiment ne sais pas comment savoir fini
un au delà des conséquences indirectes
convient d'évoquer beaucoup
s'interrogent sur l'utilité d'un tel
report la question c'est de savoir si le
président va vraiment avoir lieu écoutez
je ne sais pas sincèrement je ne suis
pas faire voyons plutôt qui passe le
plus faible devient le monde ah ça c'est
sûr parce qu'à y ait des jeunes qui
peuvent voter maintenant qu'ils sont
plus européistes
c'est intéressant que le break site a
fallu le résultat que les britanniques
connaissent beaucoup mieux maintenant
comment sa fonction des revenus d'une
européens qui avons équipé et crêpes et
pendant la campagne
tous les européens de tous les pays même
les pays avec des partis de droite
populiste nationaliste comme la france
l'italie savine il pénétra tous ces pays
là il ne parle plus de l'idée de sortir
et on n'écoute pas tellement
l'accélération de france et italie le
break c'est un espèce de vaccins contre
tous a donné tout ce que le président du
conseil européen on n'a jamais caché
être favorable à un maintien du royaume
uni dans l'union européenne une
révocation de l'article 50 une
annulation du président ça serait
possible
six millions de personnes l'ont signée
une pétition pour demander la révocation
de l'article 50 dont tu as pour moi a
été arrêté en rond étatiste il un vrai
européen qui respecte le rôle joué par
le royaume uni dont le projet européen
c'est vrai que le royaume uni a toujours
eu une espèce de statut un peu différent
des autres on ne fait pas partie de
l'euro on ne fait pas partie de schengen
de la politique d'asile et d'immigration
et tout ça est à mon avis la sortie du
royaume uni total
surtout avec un bon accord un braque
c'est très dur va affaiblir le royaume
uni économiquement et politiquement
et en terme de sécurité et en même temps
affaiblir les 27 qui reste sans nous
alors restez dans l'union européenne
à mon avis ce serait préférable mais
force pour faire ça il faudra à mon avis
avoir une des zones
merci beaucoup de chance d'avoir été
notre invité aujourd'hui comme promis
nous prenons maintenant la direction de
l'italie où les européennes vont avoir
valeur de test pour la coalition
populiste au pouvoir depuis un an un
pays d'un peu plus de 60 millions
d'habitants dont le poids économique
représente 11 de 22% ont du pib de
l'union européenne l'italie est un
membre fondateur et envoie au parlement
73 eurodéputés à sa tête un président de
la république aux pouvoirs limités
sérgio matar est là et un président du
conseil plutôt effacé giuseppe compté
car dans la péninsule
les véritables tenants du pouvoir sont
les deux vice-présidents du conseil
luigi di maio issu du mouvement 5
étoiles et surtout matteo salvini de la
ligue
les deux formations sortie victorieuse
des urnes lors des législatives
aujourd'hui c'est le parti d'extrême
droite qui caracole en tête des sondages
l'italie a la preuve du scrutin européen
c'est un reportage signé cécile siksou
[Musique]
il ya cinq ans dario tambour anneaux a
rangé sa blouse de dentiste désigné via
internet comme candidat par les
militants du mouvement 5 étoiles un
mouvement anti système
il a été élu député européen oui c'est
vrai ça c'est la homepage de rousseau
c'est là que je me log avec mon profil
on n'est plus au filet je vais arriver
en 2014 avec une réputation qui ne
correspondaient pas à la réalité
il disait que l'on était incompétent
avec une attitude populiste et
destructrice avant de démontrer en
travaillant dans les commissions et en
suivant presque tous les textes de loi
dès le départ que cette image qu'on nous
avait collé ne correspondaient pas à la
réalité et ceci a été un succès
le 26 mai prochain il sera plus
difficile pour lui de se faire une place
au parlement européen
les intentions de vote pour son
mouvement les 5 étoiles au pouvoir en
italie depuis un an ses frites dans les
sondages mais dario tambour anneaux a du
mal à le reconnaître sondages ne sont
pas fiables parce que ces dernières
années c'est comme si les algorithmes ne
réussissait pas à avoir une perception
de la réalité de l'électorat la star de
l'électro l'avant
[Musique]
pour ce politologue les tendances sont
claires la ligue
l'autre parti d'extrême droite du
gouvernement qui a obtenu 17 % aux
dernières législatives il ya un an
surpasse désormais son allié le
mouvement 5 étoiles quatre mois après
les élections il avait 30 ans poussant
et déjà ils ont gagné gagner gagner
gagner maintenant séparés trasim 36%
l'homme fort salvini il y a une
tradition en italie qui il y à beaucoup
d électeurs qui prend ses décisions dans
les derniers 48 ou même 24 heures
l'histoire nous dit que les électeurs
qui prend ses décisions dans les
derniers moments
ils votent pour la plage les proposer
fort matteo salvini dario crie pas le
connais bien il a été son attaché
parlementaire à bruxelles si ce jeune
député italien élu en mars dernier
encore du mal à se faire un nom
[Musique]
il n'a pas d'inquiétude pour son parti
très populaire grâce à son mentor le
ministre de l'intérieur et sa politique
anti migrants là l'idée a mise désormais
sur les thématiques économiques
elle pourrait rafler entière des ciels
italien au parlement européen le 26 mai
prochain
il ya cinq ans on faisait 4 % en ce
moment la ligue est à 35 % en cinq ans
on a complètement changé la physionomie
politique en italie et on se prépare à
le faire en europe possible en devenant
le parti le plus puissant qui n'aura pas
qu'on mette pas ils vont pas devenir la
première force politique de l'union
c'est désormais l'objectif de matteo
salvini initialement hostile à l'europe
l'homme fort de l'italie a changé de
stratégie ils comptent
à l'issue de ces élections créer un
groupe des partis souverainistes qui
pourrait peser sur les décisions de
bruxelles
il va ainsi dans le sens des italiens
attachée à l'europe qui dans leur
majorité iront voter en est appelée à
manquer j'espère que tout le monde va
aller voter parce que l'europe c'est une
grande conquête on doit la garder mais
j'espère comme à chaque fois que l'on
défend les intérêts de l'italie de notre
pays
j'attends que les choses changent la
sinistre là et que la gauche puisse être
ce qu'elles étaient avant
la gauche italienne marginalisés depuis
sa débâcle aux législatives il ya un an
compte sur ce scrutin européen pour
renaître de ses cendres
le parti démocrate a élu son nouveau
chef
nicola zingaretti lit armoire est
mobilisé contre toute attente 1 million
600 mille votants pour ces primaires
tout de suite après cette élection il y
a eu dans les sondages ou petite
croissance de la gauche c'est à dire
c'est comme si les gens ont des gauchers
attendez on signale de vie non en fait
recette à la personne tarif à louis ii
le prince tamino juste en commun ce ton
l'impression est que mouvant 5 étoiles
et ligue du nord
ils font le gouvernement et l'opposition
à eux mêmes dans le même temps et ça
c'est pas bientôt la démocratie ce n'est
pas bien bien sûr pour la gauche qui n'a
pas d' espace où chercher à montrer sa
voix pour les italiens l'enjeu de ces
européennes serait d'éviter que la
coalition entre l'allier le mouvement
sac étoiles déjà fissuré n'arrive au
point de rupture et provoque une crise
interne et de nouvelles élections
législatives
[Musique]
vous avez rejoint la république en
marche il ya un an à vos côtés
aujourd'hui alberto romagnoli bonjour
vous êtes le spécialiste des affaires
européennes pour la rai la télévision
publique italienne
première question pour vous alberto
romagnoli on a vu dans ce reportage dans
cette tendance qui semble s'inverser
avec le parti de matteo salvini qui
pourrait remporter plus du tiers des
sièges italien dans le futur parlement
européen comment vous l'expliquez vous
savez l'italienne zone des problèmes
l'économie et l'immigration
et dans les deux domaines ils pensent
que c'est la faute de l'europe sur
l'économie parce qu'il ya des règles
européennes et qui sont excellents cela
l'allemagne ont dit que on a créé
l'hérault la façon allemande et c'est
vrai que le niveau de vie des italiennes
ces pillards après 20 ans d'euros et
l'immigration nous on est là c'est seul
par l'europe
et ça il ya des autres chefs des
gouvernements qui dit et c'est vrai on à
faire qu'à part que c'est de passer pour
les italiennes donc une solidarité
vis-à-vis des des italiens mais aussi le
mouvement 5 étoiles qui a peut-être du
mal à trouver sa place face à matteo
salvini qui est extrêmement médiatique
oui c'est le débat de ces heurts on a
peut-être un guerre en libye et cette
vigne il dit il ya des centaines de
milliers d'émigrants qui vont arriver en
italie et les ports d'alien ils vont
rester fermés et 5 étoiles dit excuse
moi s'il ya des gens qui vont
fuir la guerre mondiale en moins les
aider il ya une grosse différence de
vues en effet sur le sujet de
l'immigration qui pourrait risquer de
fracturer cette coalition en tout cas
matteo salvini et emmanuel macron qui se
sont désignés mutuellement comme
principal adversaire de notre en europe
est ce que c'est aussi le moyen gilles
pargneaux d'éviter le clivage
traditionnel droite gauche selon vous en
ce qui me concerne
à l'occasion de ces élections
européennes du 26 mai le combat que nous
devons avoir c'est démontrer que
l'europe c'est la solution et non pas le
problème comme vous venez de l'indiquer
donc il y à la nécessité d'expliquer
d'expliquer que par exemple la
problématique grandissante en matière
économique
les difficultés économiques que l'italie
peut avoir c'est parce que nous aurons
une nouvelle politique industrielle
européenne que nous pourront
effectivement résoudre des problèmes
économiques
c'est parce que nous pourrons à
l'échelle de l'europe développée une
petite migratoires notamment comme nous
le proposons avec des pays du sud du
pourtour de la méditerranée européen
pour qu'on ait une union de solidarité
sur la migration etc un puck ensuite
donc on puisse avoir une répartition
entre ces pays
mais sur ces dossiers il ya aussi ce
positionnement contre les nationalistes
évidemment donc à partir du moment où
ceux qui sont anti européens comme les
nationalistes veulent moins d'europe
nous devons donc ainsi expliqué aux
italiens aux français et à d'autres
membre de l'union européenne que la
solution c'est pas moins d'europe c'est
pas de se recroqueviller derrière ses
frontières au contraire nous y
trouverons des solutions parce que nous
aurons une politique européenne baisser
parce que nous aurons la possibilité de
développer des politiques de migration
solidaire avec cette union de solidarité
que nous proposons que nous arriverons à
trouver cette solidarité et ce partage
de la politique migratoire
alors on va justement écouter cette
journaliste sur le thème de
l'immigration en italie dans la campagne
les thèmes économiques c'est peut-être
le plus important suivi du thème des
migrations se et l'italie a beaucoup
payé en termes de devoir gérer les
migrations qui arrivent d'afrique est
très souvent on a dit on ne manque pas
et l'europe de notre côté et donc ça
c'est en deuxième thème dans ce moment
on en parle un peu moins que dans un
mois passé mais je suis sûr que ça va
revenir bientôt
voilà donc l'immigration va beaucoup ont
parlé on en a beaucoup parlé dans ce
débat mais matteo salvini semble changer
un peu de stratégie recentrer son
discours finalement sur l'économie
alberto romagnoli des mains sales vinyle
commet vous avez monté dans les sujets
va devenir la première force politique
européenne et l'idée c'est de faire des
alliances avec des autres pays pour
changer les règles européennes
après on sait c'est toujours très
difficile mais c'est vrai qu'il ya un
problème sur les règles au printemps que
la construction de l'aide et l'euro
s'est pas complet et ça fait des années
et des années
et alors pas seulement les italiennes je
pense qu'ils ont peur de l'espoir que
les robes à changer leur vie d'alain il
ya débat en france aussi sur ça il faut
faire comprendre également à l'occasion
de ces élections européennes que
il faut effectivement changer l'europe
il faut qu'on ait plus d'équité fiscale
car on doit éviter à l'intérieur même de
la zone euro des inégalités fiscales
fiscales telles que nous pouvons les
constater et les connaître et nous
devons aussi avoir une gouvernance
économique de la zone euro qui permette
ne pas avoir une seulement qu'une
politique financière une monnaie unique
comme vous le rappelez fort justement à
l'instant les problèmes c'est fini les
grenats terre il va dépenser plus pour
lancer les investissements
oui il dit nous ne pouvons pas relancer
l'investissement parce que bruxelles dit
toujours non ça c'est voilà et donc nous
nous proposons dans le cadre de cette de
ce combat contre des conservateurs
contre les libéraux la création d'un
fonds d'ajustement sur la mondialisation
doté d'un milliard d'euros pour pouvoir
faire ces investissements industriels
stratégiques à l'échelle de l'europe où
il ya un sujet économique qui semble
diviser la coalition c'est l'adhésion
récente de l'italie aux fameuses routes
de la soie
ce grand projet d'infrastructure chinois
écoutez notre objectif avec cet accord
est de commencer à rééquilibrer une
disproportion qui fait qu'il y attend de
made in china qu'il vient en italie
metropcs l'eau de mer et l'italie qui va
en chine la chine alors le mouvement
cinq étoiles a salué cet accord matteo
salvini a plutôt pris ses distances mais
il ya surtout les partenaires européens
de l'italie qui s'inquiètent de ce
projet gilles pargneaux paix quand on
entend monsieur di maio s'exprimer comme
il vient de le faire c'est exactement ce
qu'a dit le président macron récemment
au président chinois disant nous
souhaitons non pas seulement qui est des
investissements chinois en europe ou en
france
mais nous souhaitons que nos
investisseurs nos entreprises puissent
aussi investir le marché chinois
il faut qu'on rééquilibre et la
difficulté de l'italie c'est qu'ils ont
fait cavalier seul dans cet accord
qu'ils ont signé il ya quelques mois
maintenant avec la chine
la chine a déjà investi dans le port du
pirée à la en grèce aussi 1res les
nommés sont les pays les plus endettés
dans le cas de la route de la soie il ya
des investisseurs chinois qui sont
présents partout en europe
là on est sur un accord que l'italie a
voulu développer tout seul tout seul
et alors que je couds que je pense que
nous avons intérêt à faire en sorte que
ce soit à l'échelle de l'union
européenne que nous puissions avoir
c'est sa copine avis si elles visent à
l'investissement tant que sur le
territoire européen que vers la chine
affirme au contraire des 300 avions
d'airbus acheter des produits en france
ça c'est pas la france qui va cavalière
seule sais c'est quoi un business
française en business européen n'est pas
la propriété de la france où ce n'est
que c'est un projet européen que de
devons avoir en tête et c'est aussi pour
ça rappelons nous que airbus est aussi
puissant dans le monde parce que nous
avons réussi alors c'était pas à
l'échelle de l'ensemble de l'union
européenne mais dans le cas d'une
coopération avec un autre état membre de
l'union européenne
il ya un autre sujet d'inquiétude sur
l'économie italienne c'est une
information qui est passée un peu
inaperçue la semaine dernière avec le
brésil mais d'italie s'est accordé sur
un nouveau projet de budget avec des
prévisions de croissance revues à la
baisse et donc un déficit estimé à 2 4 %
c'est exactement le chiffre qui avaient
été jugées inacceptables par bruxelles à
l'automne dernier alberto rui vilar qui
a une autre bataille entre rome et
bruxelles après les élections
européennes
c'est très évident qu est
les gourmands étonnante pensé jouer
cette bataille avec un grain armée de
héros députés pour être avec des amis
dans les pays de l'est dans des amis
même en allemagne
et même en france avec madame le pen 30%
rappeler toujours que un endettement
excessif
une nuit à la croissance économique et
nuit au développement donc il faut
effectivement veillée c'est ce que fait
je pense avec justesse pierre moscovici
le commissaire européen en ce domaine
pour permettre est ce que nos états
membres n'est pas un endettement
excessif
on a trouvé un accord ces derniers mois
avec ce nouveau gouvernement italien et
la commission européenne
donc moi j'ai bon espoir que nous
pourrons après les élections européennes
continuer le dialogue pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse trouver ce point
d'équilibré entre un endettement qui ne
doit pas être exhaustif et ce dialogue
neuf qui doit permettre à chacun de
pouvoir développer son industrie où son
économie pour plus de croissance et ce
dialogue il peut se faire avec la ligne
mais évidemment qu'il s'est fait avec le
gouvernement italien que ce soit
les cinq étoiles où la ligue puisque le
gouvernement est constitué de ces deux
formations en tout cas pour revenir à la
campagne
en italie la campagne pour les
européennes le parti démocrate a mis le
cap le cap à gauche avec l'élection à sa
tête de nicola zingaretti un qui était
le plus à gauche des candidats dans ces
primaires est ce que vous pensez que le
parti démocrate avec ce nouveau
président va être plus audible vis-à-vis
de cette coalition en italie c'est très
difficile parce que comme dire de la
plupart des italiennes le gect
l'expérience des gouvernements de gauche
de cinq dernières années c'est-à-dire
n'a pas vidé notre et réussir leur
regrettée doit démontrer que c'est un
peu différent beaucoup plus différent
des derrien si c'est vrai aussi que
encore les regarder l'heure l'europe
c'est un défi c'est à dire montrer que
l'europe ça marche sur l'immigration et
sur l'économie
et comme je disais ça prend de temps
pour sept projets et les italiennes de
progrès jour par jour
ca c je dirais qu'il ya montrent
différents entre bruxelles et rome
l'italie au défi à des dossiers
migratoires et économique pour ces
élections européennes merci à tous les
deux d'avoir été nos invités aujourd'hui
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
replay sur nos différents sites lcpan
public sénat et rtbf.be à bientôt pour
un nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
[Musique]